in ancient china somewhere around the
year 500
bce the great scholar laozi
was working as a keeper of records for
the ruling
dynasty his name lao tzu
literally translates to the old master
and the story implies that he was a
scholar of some prominence having
an important position within the empire
and being a
very greatly learned man but one day
possibly because of political
instability and the increasing
immorality of the rulers
lao tzu became disillusioned with his
job and position
and decided to give it all up he left
his position as
keeper of records all of his belongings
and started walking
his destination away from china
into the mountains to live the rest of
his life as a hermit
but just as lautzer reached the very
borders of what was then
china he was stopped by a guard by the
name of
jin-chi who recognized the old master
his reputation had preceded him
and the guard recognized him as a great
scholar
after lao tzu had explained his
intentions to leave china and live as a
hermit
the guard would not let him pass unless
he would disclose to him some of his
great knowledge
lautzer agreed and proceeded on the spot
to write down in text a summary of his
knowledge in about 5 000
chinese characters or 81 brief chapters
he then handed the text to the guard
before stepping across the border
into the unexplored frontier never to be
seen
again the text that he wrote down became
known as the
dao de jing and is also sometimes named
after its author
laut and it became the most central and
foundational text of
taoism one of china's most important and
significant religious and philosophical
traditions
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the story i just told you is of course
very romantic
and fascinating but the problem with the
story is that it most likely isn't
true we aren't even sure if the old
master himself
lao tzu is even a real historical person
but that doesn't change the fact that
the text that he wrote down
the text that is attributed to him the
dao dejing
has become one of the most important and
influential
texts in world history and especially
for the traditions of
taoism and chinese religion in general
taoism is considered one of the main
religious traditions of
china alongside confucianism and
buddhism
not to call it a religion in the western
sense can become somewhat problematic as
we will see
but we should not neglect its importance
the name
taoism is based on that central concept
called
dao it is mentioned and talked about in
all the central taoist texts and serves
as a kind of unifying theme
it can sometimes be spelled tau with the
t but this is the same word that is just
written differently because translating
chinese characters can be very difficult
because it's a completely different
language a completely different alphabet
but so what is
the dao we can consult the very opening
chapters of the dao de jing to maybe get
an
answer quote the tao way that can be
articulately described is
not the unchanging tao or way the name
that can be said
out loud is not the unchanging name
okay so that wasn't very helpful
obviously but it is an important
starting point to understand this
concept
the dao to these philosophers and
writers is something that cannot be
described it cannot be
articulated it cannot be understood in
any conceptual sense
so really the whole enterprise of me
trying to explain this to you goes
against the very foundational idea of
the thing i am trying to explain
but i'm gonna try anyway the word tao
literally means as you may have seen
from the translation
a way or path it is a word that has a
very long history in the chinese and
long precedes laozi and taoism itself
it can mean a literal way or path like
one you walk on but can also mean path
as in a certain school of thought or a
tradition
like we would say like a path to
enlightenment or something like that
in ancient china then there were many
different daos
the the school of confucius known as
confucianism was one kind of
dao and the school of mozar which was
another philosopher
it was another tao so thou
was used to denote a certain path or way
to truth or the right way to structure
society or the cosmos to use more modern
examples we could see
communism as a kind of dao or fascism
also as a kind of dao
in in general sense that kind of
approach to life and the world in
general that is also
a dao but sometimes during the so-called
warring states period in the last few
centuries bce
there appeared some philosophers and
writers who would turn the concept of
the dao
on its head completely the first among
these is thought to be
lao tzu the old master but as i said it
is quite likely that he never actually
existed
many scholars today instead believe that
the dao de jing may have been composed
by many
different authors and the name lao tzu
being used as a kind of pseudonym for
this larger group of writers this was
quite common back in ancient times
but regardless of its actual authorship
the text is obviously
very old and still served as the
foundational text for what would become
taoism as the or
maybe the first text in that kind of
school of thought we have found copies
of the text from around 300 bce so we
know that at least
it is from that early on in history the
second central text comes a century or
two later and is known as the druntz
named after its author well trump
who lived sometime in the 4th century
bce
this text very much expands on the
themes discussed in the dao de jing and
let me tell you this text is one of my
absolute favorite pieces of literature
in the
world it is just filled with incredibly
engaging
philosophical ideas and and discussions
but at the same time
also contains a great deal of humor and
irony and bizarre imagery it's just
absolutely magnificent these authors in
their text as well as other similar
thinkers at the time
present a new theory or idea of what the
dao is
one that is often kind of a commentary
on other schools of thought at the time
especially in the drantzer who lived
after both confucius and moz so he even
talks about these other philosophers in
his text
and then in his text he often critiques
them and so his idea of the dao
is often in response to or in kind of
like a play
with these other philosophers two lao
tzu and dranzer the dao is no longer
just a path or way to follow to truth
in a kind of ironic twist the dao
becomes the very principle of
existence and the universe these new
so-called taoist
writers and philosophers had an ironic
view of the dao to use the words of the
scholar brook siporin
in this context dao was precisely what
is free of purpose and
specific guidelines the exact opposite
of the traditional meaning of
tao that dao which cannot be described
or articulated is often explained as the
way of
nature that the universe and nature has
a natural
flow or process to it and that this is
the dao
now this isn't untrue it's
pretty accurate but the tao is also much
more than that
the dao especially in the drones is like
the very substance of existence
and the world it is a kind of oneness
that hides beneath
all apparent multiplicity in an early
section of the drawn sir the author has
a wonderful way of explaining this
the tao is like the wind he says that
travels through different
holes of different shapes and sizes and
depending on the shape and size of the
hole this wind makes
different kinds of noises so the things
in this world including
us can be seen as these noises that the
wind expresses each noise is like the
individual things in the world
they are created by the emptiness of the
holes
but ultimately they are all the wind
that is the dow
that is whistling in different tones
quote
a light breeze brings a small harmony
while a
powerful gale makes for harmony vast and
grand
and once the sharp wind has passed all
the holes return
to their silent emptiness so in a way
the dao
is everything and at the same time it is
nothing in particular
it's something that cannot be understood
or grasped but at the same time it is
the very essence of everything that we
experience
it is a natural way in which it flows
and unfolds and this
flow is very central to the taoist text
that i mentioned
with this foundation in mind what then
is the actual message of these
daoist texts since we can only summarize
it very briefly
the goal of human life is to live
according to or live in harmony with the
tao
whereas other schools of thought often
focus their dao
on following certain societal principles
for example
confucius was very ritualistically
focused
performing the right ritual showing
filial purity towards your parents
the taoist authors went the completely
opposite way the way of the tao is
simple it's spontaneous and it's free
it critiques the ritualism of the
confusion thinkers for example their
formal legalisms and practices instead
one should live in utter
simplicity flowing with the dao when
rejecting
one's individual self this flowing with
the natural way of nature
is often expressed through the concept
of wu way
often translated to inaction or action
without intent
now inaction should not be seen as a
kind of apathy
or just sitting around doing nothing
instead it refers to a kind of
acceptance of the events of life and the
flow
of the universe wu way means to not go
against our nature
not to impose our individual will on
events but simply to let them happen
to let the dao do its thing as it were
like water we should flow with the
rhythm of the natural way and to be in
harmony with it
instead of resisting the wave and being
destroyed we should
ride the wave quote the consummate
person has no fixed identity
the spirit man has no particular merit
the sage
has no one name but inaction
is at the same time the ultimate action
it is not passivity but action without
effort there's a difference
so just like nature the sage gets the
most done
through inaction quote the sage produces
results and does not brag about it
he produces results but does not praise
himself for it
he produces results but does not boast
about it
he produces results because that's what
he would do and he gets things done
without using any force lao tzu also has
a great section about
water quotes the greatest good is like
water
water's virtue is that it benefits all
creatures but contends with none
it resides in places most men hate thus
it takes after the way or tao so this
has clear
ethical implications the sage the sort
of
enlightened man is supposed to be light
like a feather
he flows like water and does not get in
anyone's way
quote he is good to those who are good
and good to those who are not good
quote therefore the wise man embraces
the one
and becomes the model for all under
heaven he does not make himself seen and
therefore is as bright as the sun and
moon
does not consider himself good and
therefore is a pattern for all
does not denigrate others to make
himself look good and therefore gets the
credit
does not make himself like the arrogant
grip of a spear and therefore
becomes a staff of support in short the
concept of wu wei is of course very
complex and complicated but
in simple terms it is a kind of living
in harmony
flowing with the way of the universe and
the nature around us
not imposing ourselves or our will upon
it but instead
simply living in harmony with the dao
the dranzer is a little bit rougher in
its expressions of these kinds of ideas
to its author dranzel himself the self
or ego is to be
conquered and destroyed as it ultimately
isn't real
the only thing that actually is is the
dao that expresses itself in different
melodies like to use the previous
metaphor
but this also has profound implications
for the ethical and philosophical ideas
and discussions that he presents
in this work in often very humorous ways
he likes to tell stories that completely
destroys any certainty around a
certain subject in an argument between
say confucius and mozu
both have very strong opposing opinions
about certain things
but according to dronse no one can ever
truly know who is right and who is wrong
instead when the difference between me
and you between this
and that is destroyed there is no longer
any talk of right and wrong
instead there is just the dao playing
its different melodies
port this is also that that
is also this that posits a this and a
that a right and a wrong of its own
but this also posits a this and a that a
right and a wrong of its own
so is there really any of that versus
this any right versus wrong
or is there really no that versus this
when this and that
right and wrong are no longer coupled as
opposites that is called the course
as axis the axis of all courses
arguing for a certain philosophical
position is imposing our own self our
own will
upon the way of nature the way of the
tao and thus it is
it goes against the principle of wu way
or inaction
it creates a false sense of self that
thinks it is right when in reality right
and wrong is
relative the author often does this in
the drawnce
he points out how our quest for
knowledge or truth is ultimately in vain
because it is based on multiplicity and
difference
but this isn't necessarily a kind of
nihilism even if some people have
interpreted it as such
there are sections of the dronzer when
the author takes very clear
ethical positions and still holds on to
certain principles of kindness and
compassion
the point is to question the arrogance
of some scholars of his time and people
who are constantly arguing over the
right dao or the right
truth he is ironically responding by
saying that the true
tao is that which neglects that any of
your truths are absolutely true at all
there's plenty more fascinating parts
and aspects of these books if you're
interested in the subject i highly
suggest you read
these books both the dow beijing and the
drawn so they can
easily be found in translations in
different bookstores online
as i said they are the very foundations
of the taoist tradition
there is also a third text called the
lietze which
is not as famous as the other two but is
still often considered a foundational
text these
three are often considered like a holy
triad of taoist
scriptures the drawn sir the dao de jing
and the lyrics
even if the lyrics often becomes a kind
of forgotten third wheel
even in this video obviously of course
these early taoist works also takes
inspiration from earlier existing
religious traditions in china
many scholars believe that the authors
like dranzer comes from a shamanistic
context which
was a common form of religion in the
region at the time and some of the early
taoist practices may have been connected
to these shamanistic traditions
but we know very little of this as it
isn't mentioned in any of the texts
another common theme is this i'm sure
you all recognize this symbol as the
yin yang symbol it is also probably the
most common symbol used to represent
taoism indeed the school of yin and yang
which existed prior to the taoist
authors
greatly influenced them the concept of
yin and yang can in brief be summarized
as the interconnectedness and
complementary relationship between
opposites in the universe there can be
no
up without doubt no dark without light
no hard without soft and so on in the
dow dejing he writes quote
there could be no existence without
non-existence no
difficult without easy no long without
short
no high without low and without the
sounds of musical instruments and human
voices
where would their harmony and cacophony
be it is clear that what we call
taoism is very highly influenced by
previous
traditions that flourished in china
previously and at this time
including the school of yin and yang and
many others
and this becomes especially clear as
taoism later on would start to develop
into something that we recognize more as
a religion you see many people today
tend to divide
taoism into two branches or types
philosophical taoism also known as
daojia
and religious taoism sometimes called
dao zhao
now philosophical taoism refers to the
early taoist texts and writers that we
have discussed so far like
laozi dranzel and lietze and their kind
of
speculative form of taoism
religious taoism by contrast refers to a
more systematic and organized form of
taoism that developed
later on and would come to dominate in
history
this form of taoism still has the same
text the drawn so daodejing is on as
foundational
but it also includes complex rituals
various
deities a clergy and alchemical
practices among many other things
this division however between
philosophical taoism and religious
taoism
is somewhat problematic and
anachronistic however
it is often a construction by modern
writers who wish to
sort of extract the pure or original
form of taoism the philosophical one
and separate it from what came later
which is seen as
superstitious and irrational strange
religious practice
but thankfully many scholars today have
started to question and reject
this idea instead what
it's considered philosophical taoism
could simply be seen as the
theoretical aspect of the practices of
religious taoism and
vice versa the early taoist writers most
likely practiced certain forms of
shamanism
alchemy or other practices that would
today be seen as irrational or
superstitious
so in my opinion we should probably
start to forget about this distinction
between philosophical and religious
taoism but that isn't to say that there
isn't a difference between
these early taoist writers and the more
institutionalized traditions that were
developed later
indeed by the time of lauter and johnson
and all the way up to basically the
second
century a.d and during the han dynasty
there was no
organized form of taoism there was no
group who called themselves
taoists so for the first few centuries
what we call taoism was simply a very
loosely connected group of individual
scholars or writers who shared similar
cosmological and metaphysical ideas
and who were likely inspired by the dao
de jing in particular
in the second century ce specifically in
the year 142
the figure zhang dao ling was visited in
a dream by lao tzu he claims
who at this point had been started to be
associated with a deity
and who gave him the title celestial
master
and zhang daoling subsequently founded
the so-called way
of the celestial masters this can be
said to be the first
organized form of taoism and thus to sum
the start of so-called religious
taoism from this point on this school
and many others would develop
into strong religious institutions that
sometimes held political power in china
but always remained a strong component
of society
to go through all these various
different schools or
traditions that we call taoism and
history is
frankly beyond the scope of this video
and also my own knowledge to be honest
but i would love to cover it in a future
video but in very simple terms from the
2nd century onwards
that would develop a multitude of
different organized
forms of taoism which could differ
very drastically from each other the
only
thing that they all had in common was a
certain
connection to these early texts like
dranzer the
the daodejing and so on as well as also
other
later texts that they all saw as
authoritative
some of these figures like laozi became
viewed as
deities or gods and were given
significant roles in the cosmology and
metaphysics of the religion
the practices and beliefs of these
taoist traditions are varied and
complicated the links between what is
called
chinese folk religion and taoism can be
seriously blurry
and we should abandon any such clear
distinction
they include belief and offerings to
various deities
spirits and demons alchemical practices
and what we call chinese medicine these
alchemical practices include both what
we call external alchemy that is the
physical manipulation of substances
to create elixirs and such things as
well as
kind of internal alchemy devoted to
cultivating one's own inner life and
purine
purifying one's soul from evil
inclinations
to use very western concepts to explain
it it also includes elaborate rituals
performed by a class of priests that
include
offerings and music among many other
things
different meditation practices related
to the cultivation of
inner energy known as qi a theme that
prevails in the early text as well we
find this in a lot of these traditions
another famous component is different
traditions associated with the
search for immortality through different
means for example
there are many different aspects and
fascinating things that i could dedicate
future videos to
the deities or gods of taoism are also
very fasting for example
and there are also components where
taoism can appear very similar to
other seemingly unconnected traditions
there is
talk about the microcosm of the human
being being a reflection of the
macrocosm
which is obviously a very famous
hermetic idea associated with the
tradition of hermeticism and which also
pops up in things like sufism
this connection with other religious
traditions is of course very significant
for the development and history of
taoism taoism like any other religious
traditions of course
changes and evolves over time and place
and none of these meetings with other
religions has been as
significant as taoism's meeting with
various forms of buddhism
buddhism came to china very early on as
early as the
han dynasty in the 3rd century ce or
thereabouts thus from the very earliest
stage of
organized taoism or religious taoism it
was in contact
with thinkers monks and philosophers
from the buddhist tradition
the interactions between these two
religions would prove both
fruitful and sometimes also competitive
especially in the early period we
find examples where there were great
animosity between these two traditions
there were examples of buddhists and
buddhist leaders who would oppress
and persecute taoists something that
goes against the preconceived notion
that
buddhism is inherently peaceful or
tolerant and open
but there's also the example of the
opposite with taoist
leaders sometimes persecuting and
oppressing buddhists but even if there
have been these kinds of periods of
awkwardness between these religions it
has also been incredibly fruitful
on both sides of the spectrum the
particularly chinese forms of buddhism
that developed often strongly adopted
elements of
taoism this includes schools like the
tian thai school and especially
chan buddhism more famous alone through
its japanese name
zen buddhism in chan or zen we find many
influences from daoit's thought to the
point that some authors have claimed
that the
true spirits of the early taoist writers
like dranzer
and laozi is actually carried forward
not by
the taoist themselves but by the zen
buddhists
rather than those pesky superstitious
folk who call themselves
taoists i hope this video has shown you
that this kind of view should probably
be viewed
critically but it's also a good point to
show
just how much particularly chinese and
japanese forms of buddhism
owe to taoism and probably also the
other way around
in general religion in the far east
often functions in a very different way
than what we would expect from a
western perspective on religion the
lines between different religions is
often
very unclear as the they often had a
more
fluid you could say approach to
religious
differences even if of course there have
been many periods of animosity and
conflict as i have just talked about
as we can see then taoism has taken on
many different forms throughout history
not only in its multitude of different
organized
forms but also through influencing and
basically becoming parts
of other religions altogether in the
modern world there has been a resurgence
of interest in taoism in the west
this is often associated with the
so-called new age movement and
other new religious movements that tend
to favor eastern religions or wisdoms
practices like tai chi and feng shui
often associated with taoism are
commonly seen in the western context
this of course quite different from the
forms of taoism that tends to be
practiced in china itself today
which is often the case with kind of
westernized forms of eastern religions
in short taoism is a tradition that is
very much still
alive today the wisdoms contained in the
doubt aging the dranzer and
are appealing to readers today just as
there were to those who lived 2
000 years ago they have inspired a vast
amount of different religious and
philosophical traditions both in
native china but also lately in the
western world perhaps they simply
appeal to a universal human condition
that longs for a simpler life
one that is more in tune with the
environment around us and the natural
world however you choose to define that
in taoism we are told to act without
effort
to be just humble and patient and
perhaps above
all to just simply let go and be one
with the way of the universe and
regardless of your opinion on these
things
that is a very tempting proposition
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you